foreign
[Music]
hardly anyone expected it yet eight
years after the third part of the Kung
Fu Panda film series the franchise is
getting a fourth film in 2024 Poe will
once again take on the role of the
Dragon Warrior in this video we have
summarized for you all that is already
known about Kung Fu Panda 4 so keep on
watching
first of all let's take a brief look
back at the backstory in 2008 the first
movie around the eponymous hero Poe was
released it is about a chubby Panda who
works in his father's noodle shop and
becomes a famous Dragon Warrior the
movie thrilled adults and children all
over the world not only because of the
spectacularly staged martial arts fights
but also because of the endearing story
about Poe and his friends since then we
have had the pleasure of accompanying
Poe and the furious five on three
breathtaking cinematic adventures and
there have also been a number of series
Kung Fu Panda is now DreamWorks
animation's biggest franchise the first
three movies alone have brought in more
than 1.8 billion US Dollars worldwide
Poe's story starts in a small village in
China where he's supposed to take over
his foster father's noodle shop to
everyone's surprise however he is chosen
by Grand Master ubway as a future Dragon
Warrior reluctantly his instructor
Master Shifu begins to train Poe and the
furious five The Village's famous kung
fu fighters were also rather wary in a
prophecy it is said that the Dragon
Warrior will protect The Village from an
evil Calamity and indeed in the end it
is up to Poe to defeat the evil Tai long
who leads a personal Vendetta against
the village throughout the movies Poe
has to face new dangers and in the third
part finally meets his biological father
who comes from The Valley Of Peace where
all the other pandas live
of course many are wondering what will
happen next in Kung Fu Panda 4. Poe
voice actor Jack Black himself announced
the first information about this at
cinemacon 2023 in April according to him
the main character will become the new
spiritual leader in The Valley Of Peace
this means for him to find and train a
successor for the title of the Dragon
Warrior in the previous movie we could
already see that Poe is very interested
in a particular Panda Lady will the
potential successor even be his own
offspring balancing career and family
would certainly bring some potential for
conflict a Fearless Dragon Warrior and a
loving Dad don't necessarily go hand in
hand at the same time the film can
initiate a generational change and
introduce new future Protectors of their
Homeland with the children the fact that
Poe has to increasingly focus on his
role as a teacher of a pupil fits the
series very well on the one hand Kung Fu
Panda has always been about how to meet
expectations and how to find one's place
in the world on the other hand Children
characters also offer potential for new
groups of viewers to relate to who
haven't already grown up with the first
three movies the training of panda kids
by Poe was also the subject of the 2018
series Kung Fu Panda the paws of Destiny
black also commented on the villain
homies his most Insidious opponent ever
in Kung Fu Panda 4 the chameleon a
badass sorceress who can also summon
villains from the past Poe must face
each one of them personally
Kung Fu Panda 4 is to be released in
theaters as early as March of next year
but this time not by 20th century
Studios but through Universal Pictures
as in the Netflix series Kung Fu Panda
the dragon knight Peter Hastings is the
producer the success of this series
could be one reason why it was decided
to do another movie in the first place
after all in 2010 that is even before
the release of Kung Fu Panda 2 it was
said that a total of six films had been
planned after the somewhat moderate
success of part 3 however there was a
temporary break for the cinematic
adventures the panda will once again be
dubbed by Jack Black who is currently
thrilling fans with his interpretation
of Bowser in the Super Mario Brothers
movie we are excited to find out whether
the other roles unlike in the series
will also be filled by The Familiar
voices since the movie is already set to
be released in theaters on March 8 2024
the faint hope remains that we will soon
be able to watch a first teaser it's
best to activate the notification Bell
for our Channel right now so you don't
miss it
well that was all the latest information
about Kung Fu Panda 4. are you looking
forward to the new film as well and what
are your ideas on how the franchise
could continue let us know in the
comments and if you like this video
please leave a thumbs up thanks for
watching
[Music]
oh